we need to start with the big congrats I
don't know if anybody everybody knows
but last month you said that you'd been
undergoing cancer treatment for a year
which I didn't know about so I don't
know that many people knew about it yeah
I was like I don't think many people
can't be quiet you did yes and and you
you got the news that you're now cancer
free right I am
thank you that's a hard thing to keep
quiet I
listen um physically while you're
working yeah it is it was hard uh the
thing was I didn't want to say anything
I don't want pity
and and I don't have a publicist that
you're really sitting everybody says oh
my God Kelly's oh you know I didn't want
that that happens I just wanted to keep
it quiet my family knew
and then as you can tell I'm a little
self-conscious about my appearance but
that's from the from the treatments and
people were saying what's wrong with me
what's wrong with me and so finally I
think Fox for allowing me the time to
say Yeah in November I was diagnosed
with bladder cancer yeah and I went
under treatments at Baylor I mean Baylor
uh Yale Medical
Center up in New Haven Connecticut for
six weeks then I came back and was
diagnosed weeks later cancer-free but I
still do follow-up treatments which I
still have to go back up for that which
are hard on your body
you have no idea I had no idea it was um
it's bladder cancer and then in March
I'm getting ready to go to Hawaii and
I'm all excited I get a vacation after
well over two years and I was having
trouble with my neck and I go in my wife
says we need to get that checked and
then they found a tumor here
so that's merkel's cell cancer that scan
kiss the form of skin cancer It's
relatively rare had it not been for this
and we wouldn't have found that so they
cut all that out and now my face is a
little I'm self-conscious my wife says
you look fine but yeah I got to be
honest with my sisters but you know what
Kelly it's like I'm so self-conscious of
my of my faith one good thing about it
though I don't have to shave because I
have no hair over here so it was it's
been a long uh battle and then I went
back to MD Anderson and um and got I'm
cancer-free here so we do this interview
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]